you have this show that's on the web
it's a it's a very good idea you've
always been a creative thinker it's
called hiking with Kevin that's right
and it is you go hiking up in the
mountains here in Los Angeles and you
have a guest come along what I do Kona
is let me simplify for you I go for a
hike each week with a different guest in
the mountains of this area here and I
just ask him a lot of questions random
questions and I have a selfie stick with
the iPhone on the end it's on YouTube
I'm sure everybody has seen it yeah you
get some good guests you had Caitlyn
Jenner as a guest yes I've had Caitlyn
Jenner I've had you I've had a lot of
people Caitlyn Jenner was amazing did
you know Caitlyn Jenner before I knew
Bruce Jenner for a long time mm-hmm you
know and and I I only met I only met
Caitlyn Jenner about four months ago and
somehow she knew me
[Applause]
but it's fun good does very well yeah I
like to just ask random questions you do
I know a lot of random quest it's not
like the well-thought-out questions here
tonight it's just random questions like
I asked
I asked Caitlyn Jenner I said if you
could change anything about yourself
what would you say you know that kind of
stuff that was well that's a good
booking to get a Jenner now we have a
clip here from hiking with Kevin I
believe this is when I joined you yes
our hike together is that right you were
one of my one of my favorite hikes one
of them not the favorite but one of the
favorites I can't say a big favor cuz
none of the people go well why did I go
hiking with him yeah you know okay but
it just definitely wasn't me alright
let's take a look at this this is my
clip of hiking with Kevin when you left
the Tonight Show yeah you grew a big
beard that seems to be the pattern for
talk-show host yeah when they leave a
talk show like talk to they like
Letterman ya know with big white beard
you decided to grow your beard wasn't
quite a little gingery the gingery yeah
and you had that beard for a long time
it's that's more of a statement as an
independent up there I think I grew the
beard and a lot of people liked it I'm
telling you this is true I would have so
many people stop me and say I love the
beard and then after I shave the beard I
know you're doing a bit no I'm not doing
a bit but and I had so many people say I
wish we I wish you'd grow the beard back
and the truth is my kids hated the beard
and I started to not like no I think
everybody did hate it but you know you
liked it at the time which is good you
are
you did nothing but insult me and cut me
off the whole time we walked up the
mountain and walked down the mountain
you know what that's called
what's that go hey back times I've done
you're always been good to you always
been good to you yeah Andy yeah you've
got him trained well yeah I wasn't
listening
that's like Conan that's like Conan we
should do another hike some Oh Kevin
yeah we should we should we should do
that sometime sometime out sometime I
will make time and we will do how about
right now no time like the present time
I say huh want to do one
where we go just well we're just just
walk we'll walk up into the stands
because that's kind of like hiking yeah
so this is one of this yeah so Conan
we're here where you work right now this
is your job this is my job how often
I've never seen the show how often do
you come in there doing this show let me
give a show for 25 year what defines 25
years I've been doing this absolutely
for a long time in New York but if you
have a nickel that actually planned the
show and yeah we have people that plan
to show a cawed Ian's here they pay a
lot of money to get in it's very
expensive
you got a great great ami oh yeah very
nice people are here yeah and it's it
very hard you want to come along on the
hi full-time yeah it's a full-time job
very hard and do you have to you feel
more comfortable having an audience when
you hide like having an audience and
[Applause]
so you you um you feel comfortable with
an audience no matter what you do having
an audience I like being with an
audience
oh geez all right okay and this is so uh
so this is uh this is an opportunity for
you to get exercise while you're
actually doing your show this is a way
for not just me but my audience to
exercise while we do the program yeah
we're burning we're burning like at
least 60 calories during this so that's
a lot of color it's just pink this guy's
just coming along come on this is no
one's now this guy wasn't even asked
half these people were just jumping in
this is the biggest hike I've ever been
on
I love this night I mean look where it
where is that look at that over here
Andy here come on everybody go go here
we go sandy how did you enjoy the hike
yeah look at that we got
I'm exhausted how about you that was a
lot of work I am so exhausted from that
hi let make sure a man with a plan airs
Mondays at 8:30 p.m. on CBS new episodes
of hiking hiking with whoa they did it
back there are hiking with Kevin you
guys are good at that what do you what
are you doing the nipples right there
I'm not gonna tell you where the nipple
ooh she touched me all right
new episodes of hiking with Kevin
premieres every Thursday on YouTube
ladies and gentlemen it no one does it
like Kevin Nealon
we'll be right back Martin Freeman is
gonna come up
[Applause]
you